Ebola has been making headlines lately and
if the hype is to be believed, we’ve all
already died.
But if you’re just mostly dead and want
to know more, here are some common misconceptions
about Ebola clarified.
Hello germaphobes out there, I’m Julian
with DNews and I have some info that might
help you sleep a little easier.
First let’s douse the flames of panic and
clear up that Ebola has not become airborne.
It’s adapted to survive and thrive in bodily
fluids, and some pretty radical and unlikely
things would have to happen for it to change
its mode of transmission.
It would need to develop proteins that could
attach to the upper respiratory pathway and
it’s lipid membrane means it doesn’t survive
out of fluids.
Because it’s already doing just fine with
its current mode of transmission it doesn’t
have the need to evolve.
So if you find yourself around Ebola patients,
take comfort that at least the air you breathe
isn’t trying to kill you.
These limitations help put another Ebola worry
to rest; industrialized nations are going
to be able to stop the virus’ spread much
more effectively than the West African nations
that have been hit.
Knowing how the virus spreads means that we
also know how not to spread it.
Avoiding bodily fluids of the infected goes
a long way as casual contact with them isn’t
enough to spread it.
That also means a panic over a global pandemic
is ill-founded.
Ebola kills pretty quickly and has up to a
90% mortality rate (though thanks to the efforts
of humanitarian workers, it’s closer to
50% in West Aftrica).
Those horrible attributes are what makes Ebola
so scary, but it also means that the disease
doesn’t become as widespread as it otherwise
could.
That’s right, Ebola could be worse if it
actually killed more slowly.
Hooray?
The last misconception I’d like to clear
up is that the outbreak is on the decline.
While the industrialized world probably won’t
feel the effects of it, people in west Africa
are still suffering.
Dr. Estrella Lasry, a tropical medicine advisor
for Doctors Without Borders, has called the
international response, “slow and weak,”
with China and Cuba the only governments that
have sent aid.
China has sent 115 workers with a mobile lab
and another 59 pledged, while Cuba’s 165
workers are due to arrive in Sierra Leone
by October.
President Obama added the United states to
that list on September 16th with a plan that’s
projected to cost 763 Million dollars over
6 months.
It’s still likely not enough to contain
the outbreak; more workers and beds are needed
to treat the sick, and earning public trust
so people can be educated about Ebola is crucial
to stopping its spread.
Knowledge is always a useful tool to protect
yourself.
If you’d like to learn more about how fast
viruses can spread, Ross Everett breaks it
down for you on this episode of DNews.
How are you getting involved to make the world
a better place?
Have you volunteered or gotten involved in
the fight against Ebola?
If you don’t have a story to share, I urge
you to check out doctorswithoutborders.org
to donate.
Let us know if you do in the comments, because
we want to know we’re getting people involved.
Stay healthy and I’ll see you next time
on DNews.